it's about the worst [ __ ] month of my
life [ __ ] has been hey what is going on
YouTube see no smiles this has got to be
one of the worst [ __ ] months of
my life and I'm not gonna get into why
this month has been so terrible let's go
let's go tell you what happened is it
now you guys know not too long ago I got
me a new car that's right [ __ ]
I got a Tesla [ __ ] that burns now I
don't get myself nice things I don't do
it it's not a part of me which is why
you guys always see me wear the same
[ __ ] clothes have the same [ __ ] on
because I don't buy nice chat but yeah
of course I buy shoes here and there are
buy like gadgets and trinkets but once
again trinkets come on that's cute
usually the stuff that I buy has to do
with work but can I tell you what
happened today my brand new car then I
got myself a few months ago God destroy
that's right just a few minutes ago
somebody obliterated by [ __ ] car ah
ah every time I have something nice it
gets destroyed and most people might say
well maybe it's you hey [ __ ] you so I'm
driving right I'm driving there is a
freight truck on my right as I'm doing
my thing and mind you I'm a very [ __ ]
safe driver I see that the truck wants
to move into my lane so I'm like ooh let
me slow down so I could get the [ __ ] up
out of his way but the [ __ ]
don't got no patience just turns the
[ __ ] right in I'm trying to slam
I can't even slam the brakes because
it's a car behind me so I'm freaking out
where the [ __ ] are you going that is so
[ __ ] important that you just don't
get up talk about anybody else to the
left of you tell you something
I'm a human being you could have killed
me I don't have kids I don't have much
people that love me but the people who
do they might cry this is why you don't
give ghetto people nice [ __ ] because we
don't know what to do with things that
are worth money this some of you
[ __ ] out there that are ballin
either to mind they're like oh my god is
just a Tesla don't worry it'll get fixed
shut up who do a person who works hard
for the things that they get when
something happens to it it's like the
tip of their penis was stomped on by a
bunch of Irish you know what do you call
those people you know sometimes I just
sit there and I ask what would I do what
did i do what did i do in this month
alone
my car gets obliterated somebody comes
and destroys my $3,000 camera and my
iPhone bus yay this is why I'm poor it's
not because I can't save money it's not
because I don't do due diligence when it
comes to my finances everything just
gets taken away from me do you know what
happened to me in Hawaii let me tell you
what [ __ ] happened to me in Hawaii I
was chillin on a [ __ ] boat right
having the time of my life we was going
to go on a sailboat so now on this
sailboat I asked the boat master hey I
don't know that bub master excuse mister
there's water get on this boat this
[ __ ] said I've done this for many years
and not a single time has a drop of
water touched anybody on this boat what
a little vibrating out my camera as such
like this to take a picture then
suddenly a tsunami comes I'm holding it
up I'm like okay you know what it's cool
this cool I take one picture of KC and
TIFF clackety-clack out on a second one
I try to take one more picture and then
a wisp of smoke I'm talking about like
this like those [ __ ] Arabian snakes
out of a basket comes up destroyed so
then I think to myself oh my luck can't
be that bad at least I have my phone I
look down onto the bag on the floor
which the tsunami hit I lift it up half
the bag is filled with water I take out
my phone my [ __ ] phone is destroyed -
oh and it gets worse we went to go eat
dinner after I decided to back out the
fan so I could go see what's going on
but little did I know because I'm so
pissed that the [ __ ] window is open
so I say I smashed my face into the car
window so my fatal idea you know what
the funny [ __ ] is y'all remember that
[ __ ] movie final destination I saw
that movie I liked that me damn me but
why the Tesla Wyatt angle I don't know
mr. universe God Jesus Buddha if you're
trying to kill me why are you doing it
so slow son you playing this game on me
you want to know the [ __ ] funny thing
about this is clearly the guy was
merging into my [ __ ] Lane not seeing
if I was there and just obliterates my
car he comes out and the reason why he
decided to hit me was this didn't you
see me signal fool
why the [ __ ] do people in this city not
understand I saw your signal I'm going
to move out the way but you have to give
me time and the space to do so if the
lane is not clear it doesn't mean you
could push your way through you dumb
[ __ ] I was going to let you in you just
had to wait and you did until you
decided to try to kill me I could have
died I could have died I could have been
dead and y'all would have never got
videos again not the joke here I just
wanted to share that story how was your
[ __ ] day why